[Music]
actor Christian Bale has earned critical
and commercial movie success with his
gritty portrayals of a conman and
American hustle a drug addict in the
fighter and Batman in the Dark Knight
trilogy Golden Globe winner Oscar Isaac
is best known to Star Wars fans as
resistance fighter po from Star Wars The
Force awakens both now star in the epic
war drama of the promise it chronicles a
chaos in Constantinople just before the
start of World War one they all plays a
journalist documenting atrocities Isaac
is an Armenian desperate to save his
family from being rounded up by the
Turks I have to go okay I have to find
them you can leave these people know
you're safe in the woods no no I'm not
safe no one here is safe don't you see
what's happening live through these
Turkish threats before some threats they
want to spare I have to get us out of
here before there's no time left
trust me it's all right I'm getting us
out of here
Christian Bale and Oscar Isaac welcome
to studio 57 thank you why is this one
help us to understand exactly what the
genocide was in a few minutes we have
and secondly why this story has not been
told the story hasn't been told because
the Turkish interests have suppressed
again and again again people who tried
to make this film numerous times
including Kerkorian who ran MGM studios
even then he couldn't get it made Toki
has enormous strategic value and
enormous power and Cooke actually
managed to get this made by
self-financing it unfortunately yes he
passed away unfortunately before we
started production but this is also why
you never get any sitting US president
saying the word genocide okay because of
the enormous strategic value of Turkey
outside of office yes they say genocide
Obama did but in in office they know the
Armen the Armenian genocide happened
between 1915 and 1923 we're talking
about one and a half million Armenians
they're killed yeah and this story
really kind of brings it to life because
you play a reporter right right right I
play a reporter who is visiting who has
a love for an Armenian lady who then
this fella falls in love for as well
yeah yeah yes we do yeah you know their
moves good right there yeah they are
caught up in this genocide and there's I
think there's a couple of lines in the
film which I think really sum up
something interesting here Mikael Oscars
characters as to my character it must be
lovely to get to come and report on our
pain and return to the comfort of your
own home which is a completely valid
comment and then equally my character
says back to him but without the press
nobody would know anything about they'll
mean in genocide it's very powerful guys
I was embarrassed I had heard about it
but I didn't know any of the details
immediately after I watched that I
started googling because I wanted to
know more about it but what was
fascinating to me Oscar because it's
violent but we don't see the violence
right yet you feel such tremendous pain
and emotion while watching it was it
deliberate not to show us yes a graphic
detail Terry George the director and
writer
he was very adamant that he wanted this
to be an educational tool he wanted it
to be shown in schools because so little
of it is known where at least in the
West and this country I think for sure a
lot of us feel that way
I didn't know anything about it to my
shame you Christian know okay so it's
it's the it's been very effective the
silencing of what this embarrassing
thing is you know we're not alone in
that you were saying yourself how much
about it you know people don't it's the
great unknown genocide and the terrible
thing is you think about the lack of
consequences for this genocide may well
have provoked other genocides that we've
seen you know in in the past century
yeah and and and you do the hundred
percent procede yes I think one of the
great things we want to make sure that
people know this is good hundred percent
of the of the proceeds of the film go to
charity which i think is unprecedented i
know i'm we should mention Terry George
has done this kind of film before about
Rwanda yes yeah and Hotel Rwanda yeah I
think that it's all about our oh yeah
yeah I think freedom is very interested
in that in in human survival and not
only survival but but I think another
line from the film that I think is
really great is that our revenge will be
to survive and you know the great
Armenian immigrants that have come to
this country and not only survived but
thrived I think it's a it's a very
hopeful message and hopefully people
make a lot of parallels between this
story and and what's happening now in
the world with the refugee crisis in the
same exact part of the world
unfortunately these things keep
repeating over I love the closing credit
it says go ahead destroy Armenia see if
you can do it then see if they will not
laugh sing and pray again right which I
thought was very powerful but it's
called the promise because of the love
triangle you to fall in love with the
same woman but you Oscar made a promise
to another woman and you he tells us
whether you keep the promise or not yes
well that's that is the specific
delivery goodbye the promise yeah I play
I play a young man from a small village
in Armenia who decides to go to
Constantinople to study medicine to
learn modern medicine and bring that
knowledge back to his village part of
the way that he's able to find
studies is to promise to marry a girl
from this village and use that money for
her studies once he arrives in the big
city of Constantinople he falls in love
with Charlotte lavon's character with
what happens girlfriend Papa 20
Christmas girl right right and you know
I think that one of the things that is
really important with this is and
relevant to now is just how important
the press is yes you know the fact that
you know a free press is so essential to
a functioning democracy thank you both
become how absolutely thank you for that
you know thank you Christian Bale Oscar
Isaac the promise is in theaters
tomorrow